i mean if you're exposed to western
culture at all
you are exposed to the
uh sort of idealized stereotypic
romantic
romantic you know exchange
and what what does it mean to be
romantic and um
so here's a test um
um let me see how to phrase it okay so
not really a test but this this tells
you something about your own ideas about
romance
uh for valentine's day one year
my husband bought me a six-way plug
is that romantic or not romantic
like sorry sixth grade plays that's like
an out like uh
yeah like to put in an outlet is that
romantic or not romantic
i mean it depends the look in his eyes
when he does it
i mean it depends on the conversation
that
led up to that point it depends how much
uh it's like the music because you have
a very
you you're both from the my experiences
with you as a fan
you have a both a romantic nature but
you have a very pragmatic like
you cut through the [ __ ] of uh
the fuzziness and there there's
something about a six-way plug that cuts
the [ __ ] that connects to the human
like he understands who you are
exactly yeah exactly
that was the most romantic gift he could
have given me because
he knows me so well he has a deep
understanding of me which is that i will
sit and suffer
and complain about the fact that i have
to plug and unplug things
and i will [ __ ] and moan until the cows
come home but it would never
occur to me to go buy a bloody
six-way plug whereas for him
he bought it he plugged it in he
arranged he taped up all my wires he
made it like really usable
and for me that was uh
that was the best the most romantic
thing it was
the most pro-magic thing because he
understood
who i was and he did something very or
you know just the casual
like we moved into a house that went we
went from having a two-car garage to a
one-car garage
and i said okay you know i'm from canada
i'm not bothered by snow well i mean i'm
a little bothered by snow but he's very
bothered by snow so i'm like okay you
can
park your car in the garage it's fine
every day when it snows he goes out and
cleans my car
every day like i never asked him to do
it
he just does it because he knows that
i'm
cutting it really close in the morning
you know when we when we all used to go
to work
um i have a time to the second so that i
can get up as late as possible
work out as long as possible you know
just to and make it into my office like
a minute before my first meeting and so
if it snows unexpectedly or something
i'm screwed because now that's an edit
you know an added 10 or 15 minutes and
i'm gonna be late
um anyways you know it's just these
little tiny things that he's
he's um he's he's a really easy-going
guy
and he doesn't look like somebody who
pays attention to detail
he doesn't fuss about detail but he
definitely pays attention to detail
and it's it is very very romantic in the
sense that
he um you know he loves me despite my
little
details it understands you yeah but it
is
kind of hilarious that that is the
six-way plug
is um the the most fulfilling
richest uh display of romance
in your life i love it i love that's
what i mean
romance is really it's not all about
chocolates and flowers and
you know whatever i mean those are all
nice too but um
sometimes it's about the six weeks
sometimes it's about the 6.5
you